hi i'm jason biggs and i'm jenny mullen
and we're in conversation
hey i'm jason biggs and i'm jenny mullen
and we are going to lay out some
superlatives why are you copying
everything i'd say i can just read your
mind
i've been married to you a very long
time that was amazing thank you
[Music]
i think that's
a no-brainer i mean i would say laszlo
by the way even if you are to include
it's just be obviously the two of us but
if we were even to include our children
or really any child no you would still
be the messenger
does it like with
purpose like he's intentionally trying
to make a mess whereas i'm just like
eating things walking dropping it's more
way worse okay people jason thinks that
this is the wrong way i was trying to
get jenny you're gonna make another mess
okay hold on i need to get to the sink
which is here and i have a tea bag
thing and tea here
jason was in my way and i was like move
move so that i could do this
jenny are you kidding me
you know we cook different things we're
both good cooks and what type of food
are you in the mood for
that would be the question if you want
italian good food meat you want to tally
in you yeah italian food if you don't
want to have a heart attack
me
yes
fair enough you don't want to clog your
arteries yes if you want to live like
more than that night then maybe you want
to extend your uh lifespan is the word
lifespan
you no one movie it has to be like of
all of our movies yeah who's been in the
worst one and and which one is it oh
okay since you rephrased it you and what
is the which one is it is it ring around
the rosie i was gonna go with kettlebell
that's bad too but i was going to go
with
return of the living dead rave to the
grave oh right to the grave to the grave
that's it because when you rave if you
rape to the grave baby it's like even
worse it's it's
like just another level of like low
[Music]
your nickname is phil's food in the
night like literally my nickname our
kids call you still in the nightmares
here
yes because the kids will get like some
like treat or something we'll allow them
that you know to have a little bit of it
maybe after dinner and then we'll save
the treat for another for the next day
or for another day
wrap it and then jason comes in but i
come in some sort of little grendel like
character after the kids are asleep and
i yeah i steal their food in the night
yeah no i love sneaking things last
night did you know last night at 11
o'clock i ordered frozen yogurt again 11
o'clock i could have gone to sleep but i
was like something feels incomplete i
can tell i'm just kidding
me obviously you know it's funny because
i was actually going to say
not that no i was going to say you uh
you have the best fashion sense for sure
yes but here's the here's what you tried
to up your game which i appreciate and i
tried but i have no you have you've
elevated the problem sometimes you still
buy things and you come out and i'm like
it looks like you're wearing a costume
yeah you guys see with that i could make
an argue argument for some of the things
that i present to you are so ahead of
the curve fashion wise that actually
it's because you don't have the proper
fashion sense that why you don't
appreciate it
no okay you have the better fashions
drew thank you for having us love you
drew thank you we're going to work this
out in couples therapy we're going to
figure this out i promise you for having
me do this exercise did you say
sexercise having us do this exercise oh
i thought you said it's exercise we
should sexually exercise later yeah okay
i missed a couple days i need to
exercise yeah you ate yogurt yogurt last
night so we should go suck yourself do
it
i'm gonna steal this
[Music]